PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLS THEM DO
NOTHING DEMOCRATS FOR A REASON.
NOW WE TURN TO THE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT.
MOMENTS AGO, THEY HAVE JUST
RELEASED A PREVIOUSLY CLASSIFIED
A VERSION OF THE 2017 -- THIS IS
THE SCOPE MEMO, THE DATES MATTER
HERE.
NOW THIS IS THE SCOPE, MARCHING
ORDERS OF UL, TO GO OUT ON HIS
WITCH HUNT.
NOT JUST FAKE COLLUSION, BUT
ALSO INVESTIGATING MICHAEL FLYNN
FOR NONEXISTENT LOCAL LOGAN ACT
VIOLATION.
AND TO INVESTIGATE PAPADOPOULOS
FOR BEING AN AGENT OF ISRAEL.
THE TIMELINE IS KEY.
WHEN THIS MEMO WAS WRITTEN
OF AUGUST AND 2017, THEY ALREADY
KNEW THAT THE STEEL DOSSIER WAS
THE BUNK.
THEY ALREADY KNEW.
THEY KNEW IT IN JANUARY OF THAT
YEAR.
NOW, THERE’S ONLY ONE SOURCE FOR
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
AND THAT WAS CHRISTOPHER STEEL.
BY AUGUST OF 2017, THEY HAVE
LONG KNOWN THAT THIS WAS ALL
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
IN FACT, THEY DO THIS BY THE
WINTER OF 2017.
BECAUSE WE NOW KNOW FROM THE IG
ADVISOR REPORT THAT THE PRIMARY
REPORT QUESTION THE RELIABILITY
OF THE REPORT.
WHEN THE BUREAU TALKED TO THE
PRIMARY SUB SOURCE, AGAIN,
JANUARY 2017.
THIS ORDER GOES OUT IN AUGUST OF
THAT YEAR.
THE SOURCE TOLD THEM THAT THE
EIGHT DOSSIER WAS FULL OF AND
MISINFORMATION AND LIES.
AND MISSTATED OR EXAGGERATED THE
PRIMARY SUB SUB SOURCES STATEMEN
THEY HAD REASON TO KNOW THAT
THERE WAS NO GOOD FAITH TO EVER
MOVE FORWARD.
AND HERE WE ARE EIGHT MONTHS
LATER, AND THEY ARE STILL USING
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
AND DON’T FORGET THE FBI HAD NO
DEROGATORY INFORMATION ON FLYNN.
THEY WERE READY TO CLOSE THAT
INVESTIGATION AND DECEMBER OF
2016.
I SENT THEM AND, OF COURSE, I
WOULDN’T DO IT AND ANOTHER
ADMINISTRATION.
ROSENSTEIN HAD ACCESS TO ALL OF
THIS INFORMATION.
HE SIGNED THE FOURTH AND FINAL
APPLICATION.
HE’S IN TROUBLE TOO IN MY HUMBLE
OPINION.
BUT HE STILL GAVE MUELLER THE
OKAY TO GO ON THE WITCH HUNT
AFTER THEY KNEW AND HAD ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT IT WAS FALSE.
AND COMEY AND ROSENSTEIN SIGNED
OFF.
AGAIN, WITH THE BULK OF
INFORMATION BEING
HILLARY CLINTON’S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR UNVERIFIABLE RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION DOSSIER.
YOU CAN’T WRITE THIS IN A NOVEL.
AND LOOK AT THIS MEMO AGAIN.
IS THERE ANYTHING ABOUT LOAN
APPLICATIONS IN HERE?
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU ABOUT THE DEEP STATES OF
ABUSE OF POWER IS NOW AS CLEAR
AS IT HAS EVER BEEN.
NOW, THE GOOD NEWS I AM TOLD AND
I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN, A
DEEP STATE DAY OF RECKONING IS
VERY CLOSE.
EVERYTHING WE TOLD YOU WAS
RIGHT.
EVERYTHING THE MOB AND THE MEDIA
TOLD YOU AND ADAM SHIFT -- BY
THE WAY, NOT GOING TO BE A GOOD
DAY TOMORROW.
JUST GUESSING.
EARLIER TODAY, RICK RIDDLE
CALLED ON THE CONGENITAL
COMPROMISER TO RELEASE SECRET
TRANSCRIPTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAD ALREADY AGREED TO MAKE
PUBLIC BACK IN 2018.
WHAT DO I KNOW, I’M JUST A
TALK SHOW HOST?
COULD BE THE DAY THAT THEY ARE
COMPLETELY EXPOSED.
THAT NEEDS TO BE PROBED DEEPLY.
BY THE WAY, THE OFFICE "ALL OF
THE TRANSCRIPTS CAN BE RELEASED
TO THE PUBLIC WITH ANY CONCERNS
OF DISCLOSING CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL, ADDING THAT IF ADAM AD
SCHIFF, THIS IS WHAT TRAINING
THE SWAMP LOOKS LIKE IT’S TAKEN
THIS LONG.
THIS IS WHAT HOLDING ADAM SCHIFF
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR LIES.
THEIR ABUSE OF POWER.
THEIR CORRUPTION, THERE
SHREDDING OF THE RULE OF LAW.
ALSO, SOURCES TELLING ME TONIGHT
THAT THERE IS MUCH MORE TO COME.
BUCKLE UP, IT’S GOING TO BE A
BUMPY RIDE FOR THE NEXT 12-14
DAYS.
DIRECTOR RAY, I HOPE YOU’RE
TAKING NOTICE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON’T LIKE YOU
TONIGHT.
AND DON’T TRUST YOU.
ARE YOU GOING TO SHOW THEM YOU
ARE COMMITTED TO CLEANING UP THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE FBI?
THE PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY OF THE WORLD?
OTHER WORDS, WOULD YOU RESTORE
THAT?
WOULD YOU CALL ON THE MOB AND
THE DEEP STATE?
BY THE WAY, STATEMENTS FROM
DEVIN NUNES ON THIS.
THIS INFORMATION WAS REJECTED
UNTIL NOW FOR ONE SINGLE REASON.
TO HIDE THE FACT THAT THE FALSE
ALLEGATIONS FROM THE DOSSIER
WERE INCLUDED IN MUELLER’S SKULL
BEING MEMO.
IN OTHER WORDS, A BUNCH OF LIES
FROM THE DEMOCRATS TO DRAG THE
PRESIDENT, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THROUGH THE MUD
FOR YEARS.